Mitten in Berlin liegt der große Tiergarten,
die grüne Lunge der Stadt.
Weithin sichtbar: die Siegessäule,
Spitzname: "Gold-Else".
In ihrem Mercedes Cabriolet, Baujahr 1969,
holt Kerstin Flöge ihre Gäste ab.
Die Marketingspezialistin bietet
Sightseeing-Rundfahrten an.
Das Besondere liegt sicherlich darin,
dass Sie die Stadt in einem offenen Auto
ganzheitlich erleben und einen, ja,
wie man so schön sagt,
180-Grad-Rundumblick haben
und nicht irgendwelche Dachpfosten über
sich oder neben sich haben.
Sie bekommen einen ganz anderen
Eindruck von den Gebäuden
und von der Schönheit der Stadt.
Die Stadtrundfahrten im Oldtimer-Cabrio
gestaltet Kerstin Flöge in Absprache
mit ihren Gästen,
Abholung am Wunschort inklusive.
Am Brandenburger Tor warten Ellen Bell
und Werner Baumgarten.
Herr Baumgarten, herzlich willkommen!
Schön!
Das Paar kommt aus Neuss in
Nordrhein-Westfalen.
Berlin steht schon lange
auf der Wunschliste.
Ich freu' mich, dass ich hier bin und vor
allen Dingen hier an so 'nem tollen Platz,
in so 'nem schönen Auto, in Berlin hier.
Also besser geht‘s ja gar nicht.
Für das Paar geht es zunächst ins
nahegelegene Regierungsviertel.
Die Fahrt führt vorbei am
Holocaust-Mahnmal -
und am sowjetischen Ehrenmal.
Dann öffnet sich der Blick auf
das Reichstagsgebäude.
Die gläserne Kuppel stammt von
Stararchitekt Norman Foster.
Reichstagsgebäude, Sitz des deutschen
Parlament[e]s, 1905 eröffnet.
Kaiser Wilhelm II. sagte, nannte das ganze
Ding einfach nur „Quasselbude“,
weil er mit Parlamentarismus und der
demokratischen Entwicklung in Deutschland
nicht so viel am Hut hatte.
Wie Sie hier sehen können, sah das Gebäude
vorher nicht wirklich anders aus
und war dann doch sehr stark zerstört.
Gegenüber vom Reichstag liegt
das Bundeskanzleramt
- achtmal so groß wie das
Weiße Haus in Washington.
Nächstes Ziel ist die Museumsinsel
in Berlins historischer Mitte.
Der Komplex aus Bode-, Pergamon-,
Altem und Neuem Museum
sowie der Alten Nationalgalerie gehört
zum UNESCO-Welterbe.
Das ganze Ensemble mit der Museumsinsel
ist eines der größten
Museen-Ensembles der Welt.
Die Insel selber beherbergt fünf Museen
mit der Nofretete
und dem Pergamon-Altar als
wesentlichem Aspekt.
Der Berliner Dom hinter uns, die Grab-
und Krönungskirche der Hohenzollern,
und das Ganze wird abgerundet
als Ensemble,
im Ensemble-Charakter mit dem Lustgarten.
Am Gendarmenmarkt zeigt die Berliner
Mitte ein weiteres Mal
ihre architektonische Pracht.
Der Platz mit dem Konzerthaus, dem
Deutschen und dem Französischen Dom
zählt zu den schönsten in Deutschland.
Kerstin Flöge steuert ihren Mercedes
Richtung Checkpoint Charlie,
dem berühmten Grenzübergang im
einst geteilten Berlin.
Es is(t) bedauerlich,
dass bis heute die Stadt Berlin
diesen Ort immer noch nicht so
ganz neu gestaltet hat.
Man ist sich nicht einig,
wie das werden soll,
weil es doch eine sehr heikle Zeit war,
in der das Ganze hier stattgefunden hat
– und vor allen Dingen für die
Berliner Bürger selber
natürlich auch hochdramatisch war.
Kein Berlin-Besuch ohne original
Berliner Currywurst.
Erfunden haben will sie die Gastronomin
Herta Heuwer im Jahr 1949.
Das Geschmacksgeheimnis steckt
in der Tomatensoße.
Also, es gibt verschiedene Varianten
hier in der Stadt,
aber ich denke, hier sind wir dann
eigentlich ganz gut aufgehoben
für so einen kurzen Break.
Und da gehen auch die Meinungen
immer auseinander,
welche Currywurst-Bude in Berlin,
Ost oder West, nun [der] das Highlight sei,
aber ich denke auch, das ist 'ne
ordentliche Variante.
Nö, is gut.
Schmeckt sehr hervorragend.
Im Berliner Stadtbild ist die einstige
Teilung kaum noch zu sehen.
Einige wenige Überreste der Berliner
Mauer stehen bis heute
in der Niederkirchner Straße.
Am Potsdamer Platz zeigt Berlin
sein modernes Gesicht.
Mehr als einhundert Meter ragen Forum-,
Kollhoff- und Bahn-Tower in die Höhe.
Kaum vorstellbar, dass hier einst ein
riesiges Niemandsland war,
mit Mauer und Todesstreifen. Hier endet
die Stadtrundfahrt.
Das war 'ne wunderschöne Tour,
wunderschöner Tag.
Ich denke, wir werden das nochmal
machen, weil Berlin hat so eine Größe.
Es hat mir super gut gefallen.
Berlin is(t) 'ne wunderschöne Stadt.
Und ich bin einfach fasziniert
und ich denke,
das werden wir auf jeden Fall wiederholen.
Jetzt freuen sich die beiden aber erst
einmal auf einen Espresso
in einem der vielen Cafés.